no one can make you a sinner
so stop blaming your wife
or your husband no one can make you the
sinner you have to choose to sing as the
bible says in verse 12 of genesis 6 and
god looked upon the earth and behold it
was around for all flesh had corrupted
peace
[Music]
god came down into the garden and said
where are thou adam said i heard my
voice in the garden and i was afraid
because i was naked and i hid myself
you eve didn't hide me
i hate myself
sin
is a personal choice
but one of the things sin did to the
mind is to cause us to blame
others
so my son isn't walking with god anymore
because the youth department was
terrible
are you following me not because i
failed in my home the youth department
was not good
we blame others
all flesh had corrupted his way verse 13
and god's head unto the world before the
end of all flesh has come before me for
the earth is filled with violence
through them and behold i will destroy
them in the earth now god gives noah
instructions
make me an ark of wood
rooms shalt not make in the ark and
shall pitch it within and without with
pitch
and this is the fashion which thou shalt
make it off
the length of the arm shall be 300
cubits
the breath of it is 50 yards the height
of it
thirty kilometers a window shout out
made to the ark and in a cubic shop now
finishes above and the door of the arm
shaft thou set in the sides they're all
with lower second and third story shalt
thou make all those
details for construction
and all i even i will bring the flood of
waters upon the earth to destroy all
flesh builders the breath of life from
under heaven and everything that is in
the earth shall die but with thee will i
establish my covenant
and thou shalt come into the earth with
my sons of my wife and i sense wise with
you now he gives him more instructions
and of every living thing of all flesh
verse mighty two very sought shall i
bring it to the earth to keep them alive
with thee they shall be nailed and see
them are found after they kind and have
kept up with the kind of every creeping
thing of the earth after his kind two of
every soul shall come at least keep them
alive
and take thou entity of all food that is
eaten and thou shalt gather to the unto
them and it shall be fulfilled for the
end of them not only verse 22
come on king james version read with me
thus did noble kimberly
in one detail
from all instructions god the bible says
thus
did not
according to all the lord commanded me
come on
that's a righteous man now read verse
one of chapter seven
up here comes more details of every
clean beast thou shalt do to thee my
sevens the male and is female and of
beasts that are not clean by two
the male
and his female a thousand also in the
air by seven the male and the female to
keep seat alive upon the face of all the
earth for yet seven days or forty days
and i will call it to raid up in the
earth walk forty days and forty nights
and every living one
substance tonight the plague will i
destroy some of the face of the earth
read verse five
and noah did according unto all that the
lord commanded him look at verse 22 of
chapter 6.
do you see the word commanding
yes
look at verse 5 of chapter 1 chapter 7
do you see the word command
[Music]
whatever god said
finish my words
nobody yes
that's a righteous man
everything god said
when god gave instructions to moses for
building the ark in the taliban
you can read exodus chapter 25 to 40
to read all the mining details
moses
could not alter
one detail
[Music]
when neighbor came from the masses
to be healed of leprosy
he came to elisha at the request of the
recommendation of the little year of
faith building her
did not even leave his room
elijah sent a servant telling god and
jordan several times
neymar went off the rails
he didn't want to become agreement does
he know who i am
[Music]
he's only asking you to dip seven times
and you're pleading with it
no the lord does not ask difficult
things
god said the pattern very early he said
to adam all the trees on earth are
heroes except one
did you know what i said
all the trees are atoms except
gold said i don't i made seven of these
you take six
give
except one
all the wealth belongs to me you have a
hundred rand give me ten you know
god doesn't get what he wants
how many windows does the thief have to
break the end of this building
and he has violated the security of the
building
god has 10 windows
how many do we have to break to
disrespect god
so the bible says if you
keep the whole law
and yet a friend
if a liar is in a cage how many bars do
you have to move here to get out not all
maybe just one yeah
[Music]
which one are you most favorable
that's up to you with god
righteousness
is doing
whatever god says
but it must be done not from your liver
or your spirit
it must be done from where
christchurch lessons page 97 of
halloween let me pray for it father i'm
coming to the end continue to sustain me
by your spirit in jesus name i pray amen
the mayor christophic lessons page 97
paragraph three the man who attempts to
keep the commandments of god
from a sense of obligation merely
because he's required
will never enter into the joy of what he
does
[Music]
heart compliance comes at the end of a
gun
too many christians comply they don't
obey
listen to the words of the prophet again
the man who attempts to keep the
commandments of god from a sense of
obligation merely because he's required
to do so will never enter into the joy
of obedience he does not obey
when the requirements of god are
accounted for burden because they cut
across human inclination
we may know
that the life
is not a christian life
how many of us we can't wait for the sun
to set so we can go watch manchester
united and arsenal are you following me
[Music]
for true obedience is the outworking of
a principle within it springs from the
love of righteousness
the love of the lamb of god
the essence of all righteousness is
loyalty to our redeemer this will lead
us to the right because it is right
because right doing is pleasing to god
we do what's right not because it is
profitable
because in the eyes of the world it is
not profitable to close your business on
saturday that's when most people are out
and about
[Music]
a lot of people the only barrier they
have is closing their business on salmon
fix that digital literature
but obedience is not conditioned upon
convenience
or profit
it simply is based on i love him
and whatever he says come on please my
words
that's the world you're going to
whatever god said
and that becomes my highest job
my highest joy is not seeing you know
somebody with a race or winning the
lottery my highest joy
is doing whatever loves it
and so jesus said
he that have sent me
is with me
the father hath not left me alone for i
do always those things
that please him
what's our subject righteousness right
through describe the world we desire to
enter the righteous describe the
judgment righteous describe the judge
righteous describe the crown righteous
[Music]
i could say one more but i have to close
make a commitment right now
help me
to obey you
as an act of love amen
the bible says for god so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
christ on that cross he stayed on that
cross that was the father's will
[Music]
he complied with father's will yes he
loved us too but
when he prayed lord if the father if
thou be willing remove this cup from me
nevertheless
not my will
that's a righteous man
christ lived that life in your flesh and
mind
then he says to us
you attach yourself to me and the power
that sustains me will sustain
jesus came to show
by trusting in him
you like to live
a victorious life and overcome his life
a righteous life how many of you want
that life can i see you right now do you
mean that
stand up with me
as far as clothes
fathered him
how can a sinner such as i preach a
perfect sermon absolutely impossible
where i fell short for his behalf
but let your spirit father impress upon
the hearts of those who heard the truth
that i tried to speak
all for my glory god the fields
and for the salvation of souls their
father
the reason the world is in its condition
is because one man
disobeyed you
the bible says we're forced to put an
end to this wonderful disobedience
that they may experience
a life of righteousness
which is obedience from the heart that's
why your lord is written on the heart
not on the liver
god
help us to love doing what's right just
because it is right
give us a love for your law
as your servant says the law of god
should be obeyed even though there were
no authority to enforce it
and no reward for its obedience because
it is a good law
oh father give us a hatred for sin
and a love for righteousness i pray and
save us when you come god in jesus name
let god's people say amen amen
[Music]
you